nhé. Đây là file Word Trên file này nó không có một cái file
nó rất là messy và nó không có một
rất là xấu và nó chỉ liệt kê tất cả những thông tin thôi
mình không có chỉnh sửa và làm tất cả những gì với cái file
này bạn có thể thấy đây Bây giờ mình sẽ bảo con AntiGravity
con Gemini Pro 3 của mình ở trên AntiGravity để nó chỉnh sửa lại
file này dựa trên các skill mà anh Ivan đã chia sẻ thì
xem nó sẽ chỉnh sửa thế nào nhé File mới này,
bạn đã thấy đây, nó đã chỉnh sửa Sửa lại dựa trên skill của
anh Ivan Đó, nó rất đẹp hơn rất là nhiều
Chào các bạn, hôm nay mình sẽ làm về AI văn phòng tập 2.
Tập trước, mình đã setup Anti-Gravity để edit,
chỉnh sửa những tác vụ văn phòng. Hôm nay mình sẽ bắt đầu với
Word. Mình sẽ tạo ra kỹ năng AI để chỉnh sửa và tạo ra
những luật cơ bản nhất về Word. Thực sự,
mình không có nhiều kiến thức về Word. Những luật cơ bản này đến
từ anh Ivan ở trên OpenClaw và đã được gần 70.000 người tải
xuống và sử dụng. Nếu bạn thấy hay,
hãy like, share, subscribe để mình có thêm động lực làm những video tiếp
theo. Let's do it! So đây là anh
Ivan và kỹ năng của anh ấy về Word.
Nào Cách nào để đọc, tạo và edit Word.
Thì cả kỹ năng này là một số kỹ năng cơ bản về Word.
Đây, mình đã dịch và mở trên AntiGravity.
Let's try to do AntiGravity để xem nha.
Đây là những luật cơ bản của anh Ivan mình đã dịch sang tiếng
Việt. Những quy tắc xử lý làm sao những file .docx XML
không phải thuộc tính thuần văn bản xử lý như thế nào thành văn
bản Word. Và một số các bài toán định danh bảo
toàn style của file thì định danh phải chia thành nhiều lớp
như là style đoạn văn, style ký tự.
và một số điều luật riêng.
Đây là những điều luật về hệ thống đánh số,
đánh số file như thế nào, đánh số trang như thế nào,
hình thức như thế nào, thụt lề ra sao, đó. Và bố cục trang,
đó, đây anh có những luật về bố cục trang,
về lề, hướng, tiêu đề, chân trang, đánh số.
Và, và tiếp theo sẽ là theo dõi và thay đổi,
thay đổi bình luận. những bình luận ở trên file Word phải edit
như thế nào, đấy, anh có những luật riêng này cho những thứ
đấy cách trình bày như thế nào. Và anh cũng sắp có một số
luật về các lỗi phổ biến.
Rồi sau khi bạn đã có skill này thì bạn làm cách nào để
lưu cái skill này vào folder của bạn Thì mình chỉ hỏi con
Gemini Pro của mình là hãy dùng skill
này để tạo thành một cái skill Bạn có thể apply
cái skill này thành một cái AI skill trên cái folder này được không
để sau mỗi lần mình tạo hoặc chỉnh sửa file Word,
bạn đều dùng cái skill này. Đó.
Thì nó đã tuân thủ theo và nó đã tạo ra 2 cái dot
rule file và core dot rule file.
Các file này ở đây thì mình đọc qua những file này nha,
thì file này thì nó sẽ bảo là: trước khi nó làm hoặc là
nó làm việc với bất cứ file word nào đó thì nó luôn luôn
đọc cái file skill của mình trước Cái file gốc của anh Ivan
trước sau đó thì nó mới bắt đầu tiến hành chỉnh sửa và làm
tất cả mọi thứ với file word đó hãy đến với Demo nhé.
Đây là file Word Trên file này nó không có một cái file, nó
rất là messy và nó không có gì, rất
là xấu và nó chỉ liệt kê tất cả những thông tin thôi, mình
không có chỉnh sửa và làm tất cả những gì với cái file này
bạn có thể thấy đây Bây giờ mình sẽ bảo con AntiGravity
con Gemini Pro 3 của mình ở trên AntiGravity để nó chỉnh sửa lại
file này dựa trên các skill mà anh Ivan đã chia sẻ thì
xem nó sẽ chỉnh sửa thế nào nhé Đây là Anti-Gravity
của mình. Đó, sau đó mình chỉ bảo là viết file word này thành
file đẹp thành file mới đẹp sao cho,
hãy viết lại file good này thành file mới sao cho đẹp,
thế thôi và mình quăng cái file này của mình lên rồi
để xem nó sẽ chạy mình đã xóa đi rồi,
bây giờ mình sẽ chạy lại xem nó chạy như thế nào nha. Ok,
nó đã chạy xong và nó đã tạo ra một file mới Xem file
này xem nó đã chỉnh sửa như thế nào nha. Ok,
nó đã tạo file mới đây Để mình mở ra xem đó File mới
này, bạn đã thấy đây, nó đã chỉnh sửa Sửa lại dựa trên skill
của anh Ivan Đó, nó rất đẹp hơn rất là nhiều Và được
thành table, tạo thành các bản báo cáo Đó
là những kỹ năng cơ bản về Word Đến từ anh Ivan
Nếu bạn thấy hay, hãy like và chia sẻ video Thank you